well these two russians were brought
into court they looked pretty sorry for
themselves alexander ivanov and
alexander bobbikin were captured and
they were members of a couple of grad
rocket units one was a spotter and one
loaded rockets so grad rockets are those
multiple rocket launchers systems that
we've seen use in action firing off a
succession of rockets in uh quick
rapidity making kind of whooshing noise
as they fly through the air
and the russians use them to bombard
residential blocks to the north of park
even are still firing them
as we speak at the moment this week or
so we've been hearing their rockets
coming in and the uh ukrainians firing
back they both pleaded guilty um and
said that they have been on what they
thought were military exercises with the
belarusian military in belarus and then
were diverted unexpectedly to northern
ukraine where they admitted they did use
their grad rockets to attack residential
apartments they looked pretty contrived
and they said they were repentant about
what they had done they are the second
and third russian soldiers to be brought
to court to face war crimes yesterday a
um a sergeant vadim shisha marine was
accused of shooting a 62 year old man in
the head in the sumi region and he
pleaded guilty to that the ukrainians
say they have it just in this region
alone 60 other russian soldiers are
going to put on trial but the question
is how long they will be put in jail for
even though they pleaded guilty the
expectation is that those lower level
the lower ranked soldiers will face a
bit of time in jail but then will be
exchanged for ukrainian soldiers that
the russians are holding what the
ukrainians said they do have a number of
senior officers who senior officers who
were commanders who issued the orders
for these war crimes who could possibly
end up in the hague facing war crimes
trials there